I just wish I would have done things
different but though she was a little
older than me but I learned a lot from
her because that was the most
significant relationship as a grownup
that I had with a black woman I used to
carry her picture on the road with me
don't nobody know that several dudes
that play with me buddy
she gave me inspiration you know I'm
saying a black woman working like that -
is just as good as her craft that I was
at my craft I remember we were on a roll
before
our longest road trip and we were
playing Cleveland and I went off on the
ass but when I'm getting at one of my
inspiration that was part of the
inspiration for me going back to see her
going getting back to LA was one of the
reasons why I like kick the ass that day
our amendment of how I was feeling
during that game and after that game
like just she inspired me things ended
with taraji because being me being an
immature Punk without him know how to
tell her that I was falling in love with
another woman named Khloe Kardashian
[Music]